[Music]
hello bill my name is Peter I live in
Miami and I have a hypothetical question
for you if we could clone or build a
human brain
atom-by-atom so that the second brain
was an exact copy of the first brain and
we decided to clone Bill Nighy my
question is the second brain also be
Bill Nye or do you think consciousness
transcends the physical structure and
biochemical processes of the brain thank
you if I understand your question we
make a replica of Bill Nyes brain very
troubling at some level I don't think
there's any consciousness or soul or
awareness that is exists outside of our
physical brains this is a very difficult
question to answer extraordinary claims
are made on both sides the molecular
people like me and the spiritual people
like others but there's no reason to
think for me for me there's no reason to
think there's something beyond the
physical brain and I say this because
the experience I had with people as they
grow old their consciousness their
awareness changes and I'm talking about
people who lose their cognitive
abilities the most reasonable
explanation for that for me is the
chemical brain is all you get the nature
of consciousness is a deep and wonderful
question
furthermore would this brain that you
produce be just like Bill Nye I think
the answer is clearly no because the
Bill Nye you have here is based on all
these life experiences which could only
happen during the time I have been alive
in other words I I remember Nixon
resigning I remember the moon landing
I remember 9/11 but this new brain you
create a Bill Nye will not have had all
those experiences he may not have played
Ultimate Frisbee with an old limo master
he has only played with a 165 gram disk
so his experience is just going to be
totally different if you see what I'm
driving it so while this is a wonderful
question I'd like all of us to think
about the nature of consciousness and
this has all kinds of implications about
how you treat other people and how you
treat other organisms other animals
where is there a gradient you know when
I go to the zoo you know when I go to
the zoo I see the gorillas the bonobos
chimpanzees they're looking at me
they're thinking chimpanzee at achill
thoughts and they're thinking about
something and their experience life in
many ways the same way I do or would but
there's something else about me or us
that's different I mean there's no
evidence that gorillas do calculus for
example at least not formally and so
there's something else that seems to me
best explained as a gradient of chemical
processes that happen in our wet
computer brains that where our brains
have managed to set aside a little more
space for cognitive thought you know for
example a blue whale has an enormous
brain but most of that brain apparently
is used for running a blue whale not for
doing extraordinary philosophical
treatises if this term if I'm wrong this
turns out to be wrong that'll be
exciting it's a great question thank you